foreign
has a conversation with him he tells her
I didn't appreciate what you did and she
just basically said he didn't mean
anything and he's like well I don't
really believe that my mom took that to
mean that he was calling her a liar
and it has literally been two years
since we've all been in the same room
and talked
[Music]
what is up this is John from the Dr John
deloney show
why are you yelling why this is the
inner dialogue folks I know it's too
much it's too much I saw my wife gave me
a look last night that was like that's
so much I come right here and I'm and as
I was speaking I was like Ah that's so
much so I'm gonna start that over again
hey what's up I hope you're doing well I
hope it uh you didn't just suddenly
start driving 95 miles down the road
miles an hour down the road because I'm
starting yelling I'm glad that you're
with us on the show so grateful for you
we even have some International guests
out in the lobby today all the way from
about Canada it's good to see you guys
it makes my heart feel good you travel
all the way here just to see yes
about about me right is that insulting
if I say a boat
oh you didn't even catch it okay that
makes
I I love y'all hey um if you want to be
on the show go to John deloney.com ask
a-s-k
um or give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and I'm starting to get
calls from international calls again
like we've had international calls
throughout the show but I'm starting to
get more and more messages from people
overseas yes email in call in and we
have made that work in the past figured
out how to make that work
um and if we can we will love it
um all right let's go to Simone let's go
ahead and hop on the call let's go to
Simone in
San Diego what's up Simone
hey Dr John how are you partying dude
what are you doing
uh not much I haven't had coffee yet so
your enthusiasm is helping me listen I
did it I had I had breakfast with my
buddy who's a physician and even he
after a while was like you gotta stop
man like I had a lot a lot see I'm
pretty wired up good pretty wired up
awesome
so um I'm I'm really thankful that
you're taking my call I love your show
and I feel like you have a way of
simplifying things that feel complicated
to people who are in the issue and so
I'm ready to be dazzled by your Insight
I hope I listen it's simplified because
I'm not that smart and so it has to like
do you remember that that on the office
when that guy was trying to explain what
a um what a profit was and he was like
could you just write this in a crayon
for me like I was a fifth grader that's
me okay so yeah we'll figure it out
that's the kind of help I need I got my
crayons all right let's do it okay great
so my question just to start it off is
pretty much how do I best honor my
husband and son as I continue to endure
like an estrangement that's happening
with my parents they're pretty much not
interacting with me my husband or my
two-year-old little boy
what happened and so like yeah I can
give you the background on that so
essentially what happened is there was
an incident where my mom was like pretty
passive aggressive with my husband stop
it yeah it happened it's never happened
before in the history of mother-in-laws
yeah I know wow I kid you not it started
with my husband was on the treadmill and
he didn't come and greet my parents even
though they didn't say when they were
coming so it started out there with like
somebody being missed about him not
coming to greet them because he was on
the treadmill getting a workout so
believe it or not that was the Genesis
of all this drama that's of more than
two years of iteration so basically at
some point later a couple weeks later my
husband just calls my my mom out on it
and during that two-week time period She
had basically been coming to me with a
lot of complaints about my husband he's
not doing this he's not doing that and
it sort of got to a point where I just
said you know what I'm not having this
you're not going to talk crap about my
my husband in his own house right and I
need you to just have this conversation
directly with him and I'm just tired of
hearing about it so she goes in has a
conversation with him he tells her I
didn't appreciate what you did and she
just basically said he didn't mean
anything and he's like well I don't
really believe that I don't believe that
it meant nothing I'm just telling you I
don't want to be disciplined the way
you're going to discipline your own
children and if you have a problem with
me I need you to just come out and say
it directly so essentially my mom took
that to mean that he was calling her a
liar
and it has literally been almost two
going on two years since we've all been
in the same room and talked since then
we've sent Christmas cards I invited
them to my son's birthday my dad didn't
come and then my mom came but she didn't
talk to my husband at all so he just was
the bigger man just went up shook her
hand said Hi how are you doing stuff
like that but even then she said to some
of my sister-in-law and my mother-in-law
that I was being a bad daughter because
I hadn't come and you know healed the
breach and stuff and I at this point Dr
John I'm just not really sure I'm not
doing a whole lot to fix the situation
but I feel like there's a lot of things
that are pretty unexcusable about this
some of it is you know my husband is of
African descent he's literally from
Africa so there's his first language is
French not English so we're looking at
racial cultural language we're looking
at a lot of ways where some somebody
could have just stepped back and said
listen I'm coming from a different place
different culture different language
maybe I'm just construing this wrong let
me settle down and just get my
perspective on this and let me just go
talk to the man but it's literally been
my dad doesn't talk to me anymore my dad
doesn't talk to my husband they don't
come and see my son and it's been like
this for two years and I'm just like
what is my responsibility as a daughter
who can has always considered herself to
be dutiful but I just feel like my I
have to honor my husband and my son
first
oh man it's hard yeah I like where are
you starting
I I
don't like and I do it occasionally on
the show and I always kick myself as I'm
walking out of the studio I hate doing
it I don't like talking about people
when they're not here okay
and as you were talking I was asking
myself and I was about to ask you
this thing that happened with the
treadmill
that wasn't what started all of this
there was something that you had done as
daughter to blow up their pretty little
picture of what their life was gonna
look like
and then at the very end you said and I
married a black guy who speaks French
who whatever whatever I'm in
right tell me I'm wrong there
um I don't think you're wrong but to be
honest with you the reality of this has
really hit me since this whole thing
went down okay like you know we had a
beautiful big wedding we you know I
didn't get and maybe this is just me
being dense but I didn't get it like I
didn't get the disapproval nobody had a
direct conversation with me that said I
don't think this is right for you or
these are my considerations it was
always just like in retrospect do you
feel it though do you see it like oh
gosh I missed it and let's respect feel
yeah I feel like you know there were
some reservations or concerns or
whatever but I'm just like at this point
in time the whole thing is just really
disrespectful and I told my mom when
this whole thing kicked off I said you
know I just want you to talk to my
husband and just handle whatever it is
that you guys feel you have accomplished
yeah but listen listen you're an adult
bothering you just talk to him you're
acting like an adult and she's not your
dad's not either they're acting like
children
right and
this is a hard simple reality your
parents made their choice
yeah and the choice you have to make is
not how do you fix this because you
can't you're the kid
you're the kid
the choice that you have to make here is
how long am I going to continue to
torture myself and my family
trying to prop up this fantasy that I
wanted of what this thing was gonna look
like and face reality that my parents
are acting like children they have
absolutely no interest in healing this
relationship they have they have an
interest in winning
that's why they're waiting for you to
come crawling back
oh that's how it feels it's not how it
feels crazy your feelings are correct
yes yeah and then you start to feel nuts
like my mom seriously is not gonna yep
yep but it's like it's her first born
grand baby you know there you go acting
like a rational adult there you go
you and you and your common sense Simone
there right
it like
you've got to stop running an algorithm
trying to figure this out because this
math doesn't work
so am I doing the right thing then I'm
basically just keeping it classy I'm not
really I'm not going to start up a
dialogue of conversation because to me
what has to happen is a direct
conversation with my husband first as a
respecting because basically treating
only him like he doesn't exist is not an
option right so I'm just staying back
I'm like I'm waiting for you to do what
I asked
and I'm just gonna I'm waiting patiently
over here I'm not you know but in the
meantime it's like your whole life
starts to get affected by stuff like
this if there's family events if there's
only only when you allow it right and I
say that with all due respect it does
get it does get affected and you do feel
guilty and you do feel bad and then your
brothers and sisters start to look at
you like dude just call Mom just
whatever and just solve all this
and yeah I've had had that conversation
of course you have and so there becomes
this pressure this would it anytime you
put up a boundary you know people are
gonna challenge it and here's what sucks
for someone like you just I could just
by listening to you you put up a
boundary like at work or when
relationships or what you put it up and
then you're ready for someone to come
try to bang their head against it you're
ready yeah well you don't have a plan
for is when someone walks up and sees a
boundary
and just turns their nose up and walks
the other way
yeah because you don't get that fight
that you're gearing up for
and you don't have like you don't have a
a like a way to dispose of that energy
when no one when they're like I'm not
fighting I'm coming over here you hurt
my feelings
and you're like no we gotta fight and
you're they're like I think I think you
nailed it I mean I'm I'm I'm an army
veteran I
like two different theaters I was in
Iraq I was in Afghanistan and I just I'm
like number one if you have a conflict
like we're not gonna have fist the Cuffs
but let's let's solve this problem so we
can move on yes
and then also Life's Too Short like I've
lost people were way too young I I made
it I'm in one piece I came back from all
that chaos yes and I'm like life is too
short it's too precious to be spending
all this time and energy trying to be
right or trying to make somebody else
feel like they're crappy because they
said what they said it's just it's so
not the way I would handle it and I feel
like I'm being sucked into this like you
know you know General Hospital melodrama
you keep walking in the front door right
stop
okay go to Dawson's Creek dude that's a
way better soap opera it's awesome
like yeah go to that one dude don't go
to General Hospital just don't go in
there anymore and again I know what I'm
saying is hard like I know this has a
ripple effect on Christmases and
thanksgivings and gifts and 529 plans
and I get all of that
yeah your parents have chosen to act
like children
here's no your parents have chosen this
they don't like your husband
yeah they don't like your husband in
their life
and you brought him into their life
and so if they can find any reason for
him to not be in their life they will
execute that plan
period wow
and that's like such a good dude Dr John
like of course he really was so honoring
of them of course he is you know in
every respect like I know she's a
husband and father you keep so good you
keep trying to make this about rational
sense it's not it's not it's not you can
never you will never find the thing he
did
do you know how many in-laws across the
country would just weep with joy if they
were to walk home to their daughter's
house and their husband was on a
treadmill they would be like
it would be it would be cost for
celebration confetti would fall from
this guy he cares about Fitness like
this is good
so you
can't
um you can't rationalize an irrational
act yeah and walking away from your
grandson and your daughter and your
son-in-law who clearly loves his
daughter
over a greeting issue that as you
mentioned has racial language cultural
boundaries
right uh barriers if you will
and not immediately seeking to go first
and be like oh man he probably doesn't
know or let me I need to just get over
myself because I'm fill in the blank
whatever
they chose to act like kids and I'm
taking my ball and I'm going home
and they I hate that for you I hate that
for you I hate that for you I hate that
for you you don't deserve that you've
because you laid it on the line they get
to have that attitude problem
I hate that for you
the thing you and your husband have to
do is to start asking that scary
question which is what we're going to do
next like what's our life going to look
like and I love
um that's the old Bible verse Man the
the greatest way you can get somebody is
to like cry kindness heaps burning coals
on their head right like I'm I'll keep
inviting you
and if they come to your house and start
a fight or start whatever I'm just gonna
kindly ask you to go because I'm just
not gonna have that here I've seen
enough Conflict for my time I'm gonna
choose to have joy is whenever I
possibly can
all right and I hate that for you but
hear me say this you're not you didn't
do a thing wrong not one thing
and can I say can I say that I'm like
I'm in I'm embarrassed yep like I think
the biggest emotion that I feel like I I
I I think shame is a hard word I I don't
know that I own it enough because it's
not me who did it but I do feel very
embarrassed like as a
as a member of the family I feel like it
reflects on me and also you know the way
the way America is today you know
there's so many issues with race and so
many issues with Injustice and I just
feel like if we're supposed to be
representative of the change that we're
trying to see we're an interracial
couple we're supposed to be you know
trying trying to make things better and
then here I have this in my own family
that's kind of toxic energy and I'm not
saying it's race motivated but I'm just
saying how can you how can you divorce
that from the conversation
I wouldn't I don't know why you would
try I only remember I I don't know why
you would try but that's you going back
to the fantasy
right that you took this hard step think
it back to your military service you
guys took a hard step in the middle of a
mess
and people tried to kill you for it
right
and then back here you fell in love you
you
um didn't follow the little plan that
mommy had laid out for you you fell in
love you found a great remarkable guy
y'all got married you have a kid you're
making a life together
and the chaos ensues
and so it's it's again it's I get your
embarrassment one thousand percent I get
your embarrassment I mean no if stands
or butts
um but you can't own that you can't own
that and I want to make one thing
um one note I'm always about go first
when it comes to apologizing when it
goes to asking for forgiveness go first
go first
the only time I'm not in favor of that
is when
it will be weaponized and used against
you and and that's in an abusive
situation that's in a gaslighting or
narcissism
narcissistic situation or in a situation
like this when you're dealing with
adults who are actually children in
adult costumes
you going and apologizing and saying I'm
sorry
it will invite a even bigger wave of
this nonsense coming over you and your
family and you and your husband and your
child don't deserve that
so I think you continue to be kind you
continue to say hey uh you're welcome to
come to the birthday party I hope you're
here and they get to con they get to
continue to choose their ego and their
nonsensical stupid Pride over their
daughter and their son-in-law and their
little baby
and I can't imagine when they're 92
years old laying on their deathbed that
they're going to think God glad we won
that argument and missed 14 years of our
grandson's life we showed them
congratulations everybody golf clap you
won
I kill this someone I'm sorry I'm sorry
thank you for the call we'll be right
back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right uh we are back so
we've done these start doing these facts
of your friends segments and some little
inside baseball how it works is we have
a team meeting once a week or once a
month and we go through here's here's
what all folks are writing in and asking
questions about here's what social
medias are asking questions about and
then here are some trending topics
across the planet especially in the U.S
of things going on and so people want to
know Delaney what your take is on these
things and
I missed a meeting I was doing something
and
So today we're talking about on
everyone's favorite facts or your
friends segment
today we're talking about the rise the
global rise
of tarot cards let's do this
get your marble Reds and your uh tight
jeans and your mustaches it's time for
facts of your friends all right so why
in the world we talk about tarot cards
surprisingly and not surprisingly tarot
cards have seen a massive Resurgence
globally but especially in the U.S since
the pandemic kicked off and now they're
being incorporated into
psychology psychologist office and
counseling offices into anti-anxiety
responses into Christian faiths and all
sorts of faiths all over the place
they're all over social media Tick Tock
you can now schedule Zoom tarot card
readings across the planet so before we
get going listen listen
no one and I mean no one is gonna like
what I have to say about tarot cards
because I'm going to talk about all your
little precious everythings all of you
so listen I don't know anything about
tarot cards I don't know the history of
them I don't know where they're from I
don't know if they're like from some
occult I don't know one time on social
media I recommended that people like
that yoga was a good practice or some
there's some great research about yoga
and Trauma recovery and people wrote to
me like do you know yoga is from Satan
himself listen
I just like wearing my stretchy pants
and standing on one leg that's what I
like and so I don't they're
everybody just take it down 30 40 also
I'm gonna be talking about your precious
enogram and your essential oils and all
that so no Hogwarts spells cast on me
and no tarot card spells if that's even
a thing okay cool all right great I
entered this I got this topic they
handed me a bunch of uh
articles I entered this with the way I
end like enter all of these things with
curiosity not judgment I went in going
huh awesome to learn about not I'll show
them right one of those is very
open-handed one of them makes me an
idiot all right so here we go tarot card
readings all right uh 14 to 1500s about
suit symbols like they're cards they're
like giant playing cards if you will
um cups swords batons and coins
those will change your life and things
like Sun Moon Star Temperance death
traitor old man Wheel of Fortune 42
Chariot Justice love pope Emperor
Empress mount mount Bonk the fool all
these different cards okay
um and then in the early 1900s Arthur
Waite Pamela Coleman Smith they got
together and Drew what is now the the
more modern version of these cards okay
and they kind of they fell into the
occult World they started out as just
basically parlor games like we're
playing these like we're having some
drinks and we're playing cards
um I in my head it's like Texas Hold'em
in the 1400s and then over time they
had some mystical and divine properties
attached to him and then they turned
into this more occult thing because they
were like I'm gonna predict the future
like fortune telling right and then
different religious groups got all
worked up about it and then anyway here
we are so during the pandemic uh Sarah
Pulliam Bailey and her Washington Post
article says sales tripled during the
first year similar to what happened
during the 2008 financial crisis uh
sales of tarot cards I read multiple
articles and all of them made very clear
that the modern use of tarot cards is
not for fortune telling or for
predicting the future it's not for like
what should I do am I going to meet a
lover in three weeks or am I going to
get fired for my job that's not what
they're for they're about stories and
symbols which psychologically is a very
Union concept right uh and quite
honestly symbols and stories is
something we all do but that's a whole
other conversation Sarah Pulliam Bailey
says it's part of a wider trend of
younger Americans mixing and matching
different forms of spiritual or
religious practices with one another
not for trying to seek or meet the
Divine or to have a relationship with
God however you describe that but
they're trying to find some method to
the madness that is their life she goes
on to quote someone is saying more
people are now more interested in it for
the self-reflection or space to get
validation and Clarity verse hearing
you're gonna meet some hot stud in three
months get ready that's not what they're
for so she says they're great for
anxiety yeah maybe I've got some issue
with that but they may not be predicting
the future but they do you can slow down
Shuffle look at the pretty pictures and
say oh yeah I'm overthinking this
so
if I think of tarot cards not as a
fortune telling device that's silly and
it's nonsense we all know that
but if I look at them I say it's silly
in this nonsense somebody just cast a
spell on me just now they have they
pulled out their jungle any voodoo doll
and they're just jabbing pins in it
don't do that my life's sketchy enough
as it is be nice
but as a tool of reflection so this is
where I'm gonna make everybody
uncomfortable
I've always said any tool for reflection
at any time is good
I include in that Myers-Briggs strings
finders things anagram
um your essential oil anything that you
use
to codify and explain your automatic
default settings to things the stories
you tell yourself the roles you've taken
on in your life any of those things that
get that you look at and go huh I
usually respond like this and that gives
you pause and you think through why do I
respond and huh
why do I do that none of these things
have good science behind them zero as
reasons to I'm not gonna hire that
person because they're an Enneagram four
and we need a six in this role if you
treat it like that Bad News Bears dude
or if you're like I'm not hiring that
infj they're gonna fail at this job
that's discrimination that's silly right
that's silly but they are great tools
for reflection for asking yourself huh I
do respond like this more often than not
and I do have a tendency to fill in the
blank right those are good our culture
needs more reflective practices okay so
number two I got a line and did a free
tarot reading
I kept waiting for like the pit of Hell
to open up and get me it didn't I just
got tired because it was after nine
o'clock but listen I did it and it was
fascinating here's what it told me
what did the card the first card was I'm
gonna find a new love soon and a new
relationship is headed my way
it's so naturally I thought well I'm
married so that's not great
um and then I thought this my wife and I
have been going through what I would
call very significant transition over
the last six months I have a new
teenager I've got a first grader so we
are out of this half day stuff we're out
of the kindergarten world and my career
has gone sideways my wife is getting
recognized at stores now apart from me
she's got people at doctors offices and
and and haircut places asking her about
the show which she doesn't listen to
right I am getting stopped in airport
bathrooms so our I'm getting we're
having family dinners and people
stopping so our life notice is bad is
well getting stopped in an airport
bathroom that's just super weird but our
life has changed it's shifted it's it's
and so we are uh it made me think back
to Estelle perel but she said
all great great I mean all adults have
three or four or five great loves in
your lifetime and if you work really
hard it's with the same person
it's so then I thought back oh yeah
we're entering into a totally new season
my wife is a different person now she's
the mother of a teenager the mother of a
first grader the mother of a guy who is
on the internet talking about sex all
the time
I am the husband to not a professor a
research Professor who's traveling all
over the country presenting research I
am the mother of a stay-at-home mom who
lives in the woods and who makes sure we
have eggs everywhere because the
chickens aren't dying and our life is
completely different and she's got new
ways of seeing the world and I've got
new experiences
and so then it made me think huh
I am going to get a new love I am I have
a new life my wife and I have introduced
stage and this reflective idea at my
kitchen table looking at an Instagram or
whatever it was tarot card
was actually really healthy it was good
for me it actually gave me pause it's a
conversation I might have with my wife
later
number three in my new book I have a
chapter called choose belief I make the
case both through ancient wisdom and
through science
I believe that one of the cornerstones
of having a non-anxious life is you
cannot
self-actualization cannot be the
Cornerstone because the the self can't
hold the universe it can't hold it it's
not strong enough and where the more we
try to shove the self into the center of
the planet the more anxious it gets
because it's saying I can't hold I can't
hold
and so you got to choose some sort of
belief and belief I think often starts
with reflection number four I was having
I mentioned this to a caller earlier
um
connection I was having breakfast this
morning with my buddy who's a physician
and we were talking about how I've
noticed over the last five to ten years
the more I go to the doctor when I go to
the doctor they're touching me more not
inappropriately but they always have
their hand on my arm or my shoulder
and I and they looked me in the eyes
better than than 15 or 20 years ago
and I always leave the doctor's office
so calm even during hard conversations
you're gonna have to have surgery I
leave so calm
and then I got to thinking about the the
research in for counselors and
therapists and psychologists
people are so desperate for someone just
to listen to them not waiting for their
turn to speak but just to listen and say
how are you tell me about your life
that I'm wondering if the rise of tarot
cards is giving people an excuse very
similar to the questions for humans it's
a conduit towards human connection I
want to look you in the eye and you
listen to my stories and you listen to
my life and you tell me about things
that I'm not seeing in my own self the
rise of coaching the rise of therapy all
those things and I'm wondering if tarot
cards the rise of them are is just a way
for finally someone's listening to me
the last here's my final thoughts these
can be super dangerous
and stupid quite frankly if they use
them in the wrong way there's reams of
data on priming I call it nudged
learning or expectations in learning
um Luna colloqua's done a lot of work on
here we're always absorbing cues in the
environment how we should respond to
something
what that means and a lot of us is
unconscious so if I think I'm going to
get a response I may be leaning that way
if I think this card is going to tell me
if I should break up with my girlfriend
or my wife and it says you're going to
be finding a new love
my body can run down that lane before
I've thought it through so if you're
going to use sterile cartridge or
anything similar for secret messages
from the universe you're putting
yourself at risk for making rash unwise
unsafe decisions and I personally don't
put a lot of stock on these things
because I am rash and I make rash
decisions and I'm a mess and so I don't
mess with them for that very reason
um if you're going to use them for fun
or to jump start conversations or
questions or about important topics or
just something fun for friend like
Dungeons and Dragons or online gaming
whatever other things you're into
knock your lights out don't use them as
a tool for big life decisions
ah you need something a lot of trouble
to doing that okay
um priming is a real and unconscious
thing so Kelly that's my thoughts on
tarot cards
[Music]
you know you had me a little nervous
earlier because you wouldn't tell me
the angle you were taking
I thought that was fantastic
tarot cards it is America let's do this
I'm a
Queen of Wands
I think that's a thing
no
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back let's go to Glenn
and Fresno what's up Glenn
yeah how's it going Dr John partying
dude what are you doing
ah talking to you sweet that's such a
great answer well played all right so
what's up dude
hey uh you know I guess this kind of
came up with this thought and
but you know email your show and I guess
you know how do you let go of who you
thought you were in this image you had
of yourself and this image that other
people implanted in you
when you know your your life has done an
absolute 180 and
your
your objective mind knows you're not
that stuff anymore but you know
something inside of you just can't let
it go man give me an example
well you know I used to be an overweight
kid I was the one that was always pick
last for Sports in the whole nine yards
I was shy
quiet and you know now I'm
fit
um
actually I guess you could say jacked I
mean I you have a hard time have a hard
time saying something positive about
myself you know uh you know I become a
certified personal trainer a nutrition
coach from your buddy Dr Norton and it's
you know and I'm like yeah no no I'm I'm
I'm gonna be fat again who who's gonna
want to listen to me who's going to want
to believe me yeah you know that type
thing it's just
that's one example I went through a
pretty pretty rough marriage pic
somebody who probably wasn't a good
partner but I learned a lot out of it
that ended
you know just recently this wonderful
woman walked into my life and I'm like
yeah she's gonna figure me out this is
this can't be real and you know I'm just
sitting here awake at night thinking
what am I going to do to screw this up
what am I going to do to sabotage it why
in the world can I believe I'm worth all
this stuff
so there's a man and Her Name Escapes me
she's from London
um
she's a researcher on imposter syndrome
and
that's such a Cheesy line like at this
point in my life I'm like dude just get
over imposter syndrome but she gave a
definition that stuck with me she said
imposter syndrome is when you believe
others are are judging you as harshly as
you judge yourself
and the reason that was important for me
was imposter Syndrome has nothing to do
with the outside world it has to do with
me
right right and that's both terrifying
and relieving because I this is a situ
this is something I have to enter into
and I want you to be really grateful for
your mind and body because they're
working exactly as they should
here's why
your Bot you've been through hell
you've been the little fat kid that
everybody made fun of you've been that
little kid that had to hide in his shell
you've been the guy that girls walk past
over and over and over and over again
and your body put a GPS pin in that and
said that was terrifying and lonely and
scary we were all alone we can never let
that happen again
and so what your sweet brain and mind
and body are doing to you are just
trying to remind you that there are
sharks out there that can get us at any
moment
and now you've got a whole new world but
the GPS system is still beeping at you
right it's still trying to get your
attention hey yeah we could die we could
die we could die and so at some point
you got to make peace with I'm probably
just trying to keep me alive and that's
different than going to war trying to
shut up the voices
see what I'm saying right and this is
hard especially for somebody who has
been out of shape and is now in shape
because you often have to you often
attack that right it's like you know
pain is weakness leaving the body like
I'm gonna Crush my way through this
thing and it's discipline over and over
this is a totally this is making peace
this is opening your hands up not
tightening them up okay right um I will
tell you and Lane and I have had this
conversation personally I've had this
conversation
um I've been blessed in my career to
have in this new second chapter of my
life is like a co-host a radio show with
Dave Ramsey and we talk about often off
air just as as friends
he still has
he's got hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars of net worth he
still has that poor East Tennessee kid
in there
yeah right and as my life has changed I
can't even scratch and sniff his net
worth but as my life has changed from
being the poor kid money was was a was a
curse in my home right it was terrifying
um I've gone back to him and said hey
man how do you balance this man because
I got this little kid in me screaming
it's all coming down it's all coming
down and he's given me two um important
important things number one
in his words the ratios in my words the
charts and graphs I've got to look at
the data
okay so what I mean by that is
um if you have ten thousand dollars and
you buy a thousand dollar car
and you have a million dollars and you
buy a hundred thousand dollar car
the ratios are the same right right in
my little brain I'm like a hundred
thousand dollar car that's right and so
it doesn't ever work and so for you
that girl would never talk to me because
I'm not worthy of her time or attention
or love
and now she does
and I have to say no no no no be and by
the way forget the jacked part you're a
guy who walks around this head held high
who loves other people who takes care of
it you dedicated your life to helping
other people through hard moments that's
who you are yeah no it's it's important
to me that's right you've got to learn
to look at the ratios and say okay the
data says this I'm not going back
and I've got to learn to love myself as
much as I ask other people to love
themselves
I've got to honor myself and so that
leads me the second thing and this has
been the key for me is
um this is not going to sit well with
the Bro culture okay with the with the
uh shouldn't kill it's not gonna say
well with that crew okay
but I don't care because I'm right and
they're wrong
you have to Outsource some of this to a
group of friends and community that will
consistently call you out hold you
accountable and remind you on a regular
basis that you're loved
yeah okay and uh my Andy Peterson here
in town uh Andy Peterson here in town
he's a musician here in town he says
your community defines your calling your
communities are going to be the group
that rallies around you says hey man
you're really doing a great job taking
care of people you inspire me I love you
and I've got to learn to listen to that
voice as data more than the voice in my
head saying hey it's all coming down
it's all coming down
yeah does that make sense yeah yeah yeah
the other thing the other thing that's
hard is you know when you you you do
these these big changes you get yourself
on the right track and even in the work
world and I'm pretty high up in a pretty
major company you know dealing with tens
of millions of dollars and it's like
they're trusting some little redneck kid
from Fresno you know to do this and it
but you you your your sport group your
friends your your close people they
they drift away because you just can't
connect anymore so yeah you do you find
yourself kind of alone out there you in
in the so people often look at all right
what's the external work to do what can
I go crush and kill
the challenge here and there is a place
for that and make no mistake there's a
place for getting up and grinding and
working really hard there's a place for
getting up and working out really hard
and and getting in shape all that stuff
taking care of your diet taking control
of your diet stuff that lane has
personally helped me with tremendously
um but the other side of it is
ah this sucks I gotta go make new
friends at 30. yeah which is the worst
the worst the worst
right and then God forsake like you
gotta go make friends at 40.
and the practice of our life is you only
have a certain number of opportunities
to make 25-year friends because you only
have so long to live right and so the
practice is less about I need to get my
brain to stop doing X Y and Z I need to
go make a couple of really close friends
that I can trust
yeah and that means I'm gonna have to
call guys and be weird and they may
totally hose me or I might find out six
months in oh they just using me for my
business contacts that's cool man that
they're not in a good place to be good
friends that's cool I'm not even gonna
sweat it I'm just gonna roll off and go
do my thing
and I'm gonna grieve it I'm gonna be
bummed out because I like that dude or I
like them cool I'm gonna go make friends
another way I'm gonna get I'm gonna have
people from my house to watch the fights
and two or three of those dudes and I
are gonna be hanging out after does that
make sense like it's going to be a and
by the way these aren't guys at the gym
like I'm just not gonna surround myself
with Meatheads I'm gonna find a
bricklayer and a my two closest friends
on the planet my if I say four my four
closest friends right now if I was just
to tick them off one of them is uh Bank
examiner one of them runs it is a CEO of
a HVAC company like a plumbing HVAC
company one sells Lube I wish I was
lying you know how many cut down Wars he
wins zero because he's a Lube salesman
like for diesel mechanic or whatever and
then the fourth one is the CEO of a lawn
care company and I'm a YouTuber dude
none of us do the same stuff but these
are guys that I regularly call that we
talk to I tell them I love them they
tell me they love me they ask about my
kids if I've got a hard life decision I
reach out to them so I've got to have
those guys they're not in my industry
they don't know the things I'm going to
every day and I don't know what crap
they're dealing with every day and
that's the beauty of it I mean and we
all all of us are different politically
we all have different Financial
situations it's just a group it's just a
gang and man these guys all came later
on in my life and it's been kind of
weird and kind of awkward and kind of
hard and there's 40 other dudes that I
love and care about but these ones are
certain you see what I'm saying
another close friend that's in in
Colorado Springs is a Trader got another
close friend in Dallas who sells
insurance so it's it's again it
continues to Ripple and spread that's my
life's work and let me challenge you on
one more thing
you probably tell your folks you gotta
have a baseline you gotta write stuff
down is that fair
yeah yeah you guys you got to be
accurate meticulous and and you know if
it's not on paper you don't know what's
happening there you go so uh I want you
to look at this on YouTube I'm holding
it up right now I've got carry it with
me it's on my desk it's my little uh
it's a diary is what it is it's I wish I
I again I'm trying to come up with like
some red like Jocko way of saying it
like this is my this is my thought
executioner I don't it's just a diary
it's just a journal right
um
but I do I've got red I got like my
goruck sticker Christensen B Wilder
Montana knife Co like I tried to make it
as tough as possible dude it's a diary
and you've got to begin to take captive
these thoughts that tell you that you
suck
okay
okay and when you have that thought that
like what are they doing like I am a
redneck kid from write that thought down
as though it's a
a box of Girl Scout cookies you just
annihilated and you're trying to get a
handle on your nutrition write it down
and take captive of it that's not true
I was a redneck little kid and I worked
my butt off to get here and they
wouldn't be trusting me with this if
they didn't think they were going to
make a whole bunch more money because
I'm running the show awesome
that woman is blessed beyond measure not
to marry some super sexy Glenn which
good for you
um people often mistake me as a personal
trainer too by the way and
that's that's never happened not one
time not one time in my life but someone
been like are you a personal trainer
that's never happened
um but she's really really lucky to meet
a guy and fall in love with a guy who's
dedicated his life
to helping other people achieve their
goals achieve their visions of Health
and Longevity and being able to wrestle
with their grandkids when they're 80.
that's work you're doing and she's she's
won the lottery fall in love with a guy
like that
yeah that's what she says it's hard for
me to grasp but yeah okay she might be
lying to you just because you're a smoke
show I don't I don't even know what
you're saying I'm not gonna lie to you
now she she she's pretty awesome it's
like I woke up and it's like this this
is different
yes so write them down
and uh I'll even give you one more thing
uh this is something me my wife you like
a tool we use all the time I did it last
night
um I asked heard the question
I say hey the story I'm making up is
you're mad the story I'm making up is
you were frustrated by something I said
or did the story I'm making up is you
don't want to go to this party that we
got invited to
and by saying it that way I'm not saying
why are you mad why don't you want to go
to this party I am taking ownership of
this I have created a story in my head
that you don't want to do this and it
invites her in to say you're right I
don't want to go and I had a story that
I didn't that you would be mad or of
course I want to go I just have had
diarrhea all day and I don't know that's
not my wife but but you know you know
what I mean so that's a tool you can ask
when you find yourself
I don't think she really likes me like I
can't believe
then I think you can reach out and say
hey uh the story I'm choosing to tell
myself is that a beautiful woman like
you is gonna leave a Loser Like Me
call her out
and she might look at you and say
everyone hear that story again because
it's not true
it's awesome to know you Glenn
um thank you for loving people in your
community and for dedicating your life
to other people's lives that's amazing
I want you to treat you as good as you
treat them take captive of those
thoughts my brother take captive them
time your default setting will change
from I'm just a dumb idiot redneck kid
too
I'm freaking Glenn from Fresno and I'm
doing some pretty amazing things for the
people in my world we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
listen you can argue and complain about
the greatest uh
soap operas of all time the greatest uh
shows of all time
but there's only one
Dawson's Creek
Pacey Joey my daughter's name is
Josephine hashtag just saying
and the greatest song ever for a show
the great Paula Coles I don't want to
wait and it goes like this
so it's not a great song so open up your
morning light and say a little prayer
for right I don't know what that means
you know that if we are
stay alive
then see the peace in every eye
dude
don't know what that means but I don't
want to
[Music]
love you guys